We've mentioned previously that Joe Biden came
into office or his first approval rating once in
office was the highest initial approval rating
of any president in nearly 30 years. In fact,
28, to be exact, dating back to Bill Clinton's
first year in the White House in 1993.
It is now not just one poll. Yesterday's
political morning consult poll
continues to have Joe Biden polling very
strongly. Let's take a look at the full
scope of the numbers right now. Joe Biden with 62
percent approval, 62 percent approval. Remember,
Donald Trump did not get to 50 percent approval
even once during his entire presidency.
The covid relief bill once passed, still roughly
the same level of support, 72 percent of Americans
supporting the covid relief bill. 56 percent of
Americans believe Joe Biden is doing a good job
on the economy. Typical that Democratic presidents
don't poll that well on the economy. That's a long
standing statistical reality, 66 percent approval
for Joe Biden on coronaviruses remaining in that
middle. 60S level, so these are very strong
numbers and seeing Joe Biden's approval on
coronavirus stimulus reminded me once again, not
a single Republican voted for that bill. Many
Republican voters supporting covid relief, zero
Republican votes in the House of Representatives,
zero Republican votes in the Senate for this covid
relief bill. And so that gets us to the question
of whether Republicans need to recalibrate their
thinking on voting against something that you have
essentially a supermajority of the
country wanting, supporting and needing.
The answer may not be yes. And what I mean
by that is if Republican no votes in the
House and Senate uncovered relief, which
is popular, have no consequences in 2022,
why would they vote for it? If there is a
political case to be made for I voted against
the pork and I voted against the, you know,
overspending, and what about the debt and what
about the deficit? You know, whatever if it's not
going to affect them in 2022 with their own base.
And I remain skeptical that it will maybe
Republicans don't need to recalibrate their
votes to be reflective of what their constituents
want. I don't know, given the circumstances,
the situation Joe Biden was handed, the
hyperpolarization of the country and party,
the Republican Party that has been feeding a lie
to their voters for two months, that Joe Biden
actually won. Given all of that, these are really
good numbers. They may not remain. I said before,
if Biden doesn't get covid stimulus done soon,
like within, I said, you know, about a week ago, I
said within 10 days or 14 days ago, I said within
10 days. And it passed last week. If Biden doesn't
get it done, it would be a major failure and it
will probably tank his approval. He got it done.
People are getting cash and they don't care. You
know, if you just got fourteen hundred dollars or
twenty eight hundred dollars or whatever, do you
care if it happened via budget reconciliation or
you got the money because of 60 votes? No, people
don't care about that outside of, you know, the
political beltway and people who follow politics
really closely. And this probably buys Biden
six weeks, eight weeks. And then the question
becomes, what next? Is a vaccine rollout continue
to improve because cases are starting to level
out. Even though we're vaccinating, we have to
vaccinate more quickly. We'll have to see what
the next thing is for Joe Biden. And by the way,
these numbers, 62 percent approval, etc.. Biden
has these numbers without even doing a press
conference. Fox News and Newsmax and others would
have you believe that Joe Biden, not having done a
press conference yet, is essentially the biggest
scandal since Watergate at this point in time.
It's not something that most American people
care about. Most American people don't even watch
presidential press briefings. However, Joe Biden
will be doing one a week from today, Thursday,
the 25th. And of course, I will be covering it the
day after Joe Biden's press conference, the 26th.
We're doing a one day membership special. We are
blowing out huge discounts. These discounts are
not illegal, but they're definitely
immoral in some sense. I'm kidding.
March twenty sixth big discount. If you want
to be notified about it to get a membership,
just get on my newsletter at David Pakman dot com.
And then Friday morning, next Friday morning, you
will be given specific instructions how to sign
up for this disgustingly discounted membership.